oh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so stranger things season 4 volume
1 is packed with absolutely incredible
moments throughout it in my opinion the
season really upped its quality and each
entry feels like its own standalone film
divided up into several storylines who
watch as joyce tries to save hopper 11
attempts to regain her powers and the
rest of the group try and stop the new
big bad wechner bekner is easily my
favorite villain that we've had in the
show so far and this nightmarish
creature stalks a lot of characters
throughout the entire season clearly
based on freddy krueger we even get a
nod to this with a cameo by robert
englund who is revealed to be the
character's father beckner is set up
early on as an unstoppable force and
come the end of episode 1 he's left a
side-splitting impression trapping his
prey in fantasies he torments them
before suspending his victims in the air
their deaths are absolutely horrible and
it really sets him up as an unbeatable
evil that always gets what he wants
there's seemingly no way to stop him
because he doesn't exist in the real
world per se and that's what makes max's
storyline even more enthralling early on
in the season he sets his sights on her
and it's easy to get swept up in the
show and believe that she's gonna be the
next character to die however max makes
it out of it and the emotion that comes
with it elevates the scene to be my
favorite in the entire show so far we're
led to believe there's no way out and
thus when she escapes it hypes you up
even more throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the scene the
subtle things that they do in it and
also we're just going to discuss why
it's our favorite moment in the show if
you agree then smash the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
day without the way thanks for clicking
this now let's get into stranger things
season four
now one thing that has a big hangover
from season three is the death of billy
though he was less likable in joffrey he
did still have a moment of redemption
when he sacrificed himself to the mind
player's minion body his death hit max
hard and in this season we discover that
she [ __ ] herself massively off from her
friends she isn't exactly having the
best time at home either and she's
basically be rabbit
in the trailer stella wagner coming
after her is something she'd rather not
go through but realizing that time is
running short she seemingly accepts her
fate episode 4 title dear billy centers
around her attempting to stop beckner
from killing her by facing her guilt
head-on as nancy and robin head out to
investigate what happened at the creel
house max ends up going out to billy's
grave she gives a letter to lucas as a
final farewell and goes up to billy's
headstone to say her piece here she
reads a letter to the chum sorry guy
that details the breakdown of his dad
and her mother's marriage how she lost
the high score at the arcade and also
her feelings of guilt she talks about
running to him which kind of foreshadows
what's to come
sometimes i imagine myself
running to you
i think the biggest issue that max has
is that she's very much stuck thinking
what could have been and it's also this
regret over his death that weighs
heavily on her now though we don't know
wekner's true motives yet it does seem
like he picks on people who feel either
abandoned lonely or traumatized in his
speech 211 at the end of episode 7 he
says he views himself as freeing people
from their miserable lives beckner
describes how humans are just living
this monotonous existence going through
cycles and counting down the seconds
until the day they die max is at one of
her lowest points here and though it
does seem like she finally gets it off
her chest it's at this point he strikes
the graveyard seemingly changes around
her and enrolls what appears to be billy
now i must admit they did get me with
this and there were even leaks in the
lead-up to the show that made it seem
decker montgomery was going to be
playing wekner theories were abound that
the mind player poisoned him in season 3
and that is why he posted photos of
himself back in the makeup chair however
the truth of the matter is wekner is
weaponizing max's regrets against her
this dream world is where he torments
his victims and it's how he
psychologically breaks them
you know i think there's a part of you
buried somewhere deep
and wanted me to die that day that was
maybe even
relieved
however max stays strong and makes a
break for it in the outside world though
we see that she's stuck in a dreamlike
state unable to move again we get those
nightmare on elm street vibes and across
the show we rejoin nancy and robin
investigating victor creel there are
also flashes of silence of the lambs
clarice of course went to visit hannibal
lecter in the film's most iconic scene
and the surroundings at this hospital
are perfectly put in place to remind us
of that movie razia the wekner victims
didn't stand a chance here they
seemingly find a way to break those
trapped in this spell out of it whereas
in the past the upside down has pretty
much been a mix of grey blue and black
here they change things up when we're
dealing with bechner as max strolls
through the graveyard the headstones
slowly morph around her into the
leech-like spires and the colour scheme
shifts from knight to red typically when
we think of hell we imagine bursting
fires red environments and a bloodlike
almost scabbing to the entire thing he's
a clot that ends up forming within you
and slowly over time he grows and grows
until he finally kills you max ends up
walking through the creole house which
has defied the laws of gravity and here
she steps on some spider eggs they burst
open like something from a nightmare and
as we learn in episode 7 beckner had a
fascination with black widows he strung
his victims up around the area and these
look similar to the ones in alien a
ripley comes across in the director's
cut i think it was the director's cut i
watched both versions so much i don't
even know it look you don't care
what you do care about is wekner who
rolls in at this moment looking
absolutely terrifying the guy is a
complete monster and as we learn he was
someone who didn't really ever
experience love this explains the way to
beat him and on the outside max's
friends play her running up that hill by
kate bush the song actually holds a lot
of meaning because it's about someone
who wants to swap places with the person
they love when talking about it k bush
said that a man and woman can't fully
understand each other because they're a
man and a woman however if they swap
places they'd find common ground and
would make a breakthrough with one
another this very much represents max
and lucas the pair of which aren't
really on the same page at the moment so
though this song is a banger it's a
banger isn't it it also holds
sentimentality to the character this is
why when she listens to it she also gets
flashes of lucas and the prior scene
about the letter i don't want a letter
we're right here i'm right here
but she elaborated that she initially
thought the song could be a deal with
the devil but they changed the lyrics to
a deal with god because there's more
love and kindness related to him they
place the headphones over her ears and
this is when max slowly starts to fight
back becca dangles her in the air and at
this point we get some of the best
scenes from the show so far this is very
much a trip down memory lane that's
cemented by the love of lucas and max
which is what she uses to break free max
starts running i don't care what anyone
says hearing the music blast at this
point is absolutely amazing
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
oh
still get goosebumps now and any run in
slow motion to a song like this in my
opinion is epic for me it's the classic
battle between good and evil where one
side faces almost insurmountable odds
however with a little help from her
friends max manages to overpower this
almost unstoppable evil and she makes it
out this basically ticks off all the
things that i want from stranger things
and i think in the end it's the perfect
scene for the series you've got a ton of
references to 80s classics a terrifying
horror vibe as scary as feeling an
amazing soundtrack and also a heart to
the whole thing i think this scene
completely knocks it out of the park and
that's why it's my favorite one from the
show obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts though so make sure you comment
below and let me know we are on a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the batman on the 15th
of june and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scene we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now save that to
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
predictions for part two which will be
linked on screen right now we talk about
some of the major ways we think they're
gonna defeat beckner so head over there
right after this without the way thanks
for sitting through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace